>> WE AT ROAD CHECK KNOW --
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN
UNEXPECTED HOUSE GUESTS.
>> HOME SWEET HOME.
>> ESPECIALLY ROACHES.
>> NICE PLACE!
>> THEY ALWAYS MAKE THEIR
PRESENCE FELT.
>> GIVE IT A MINUTE.
>> AND ONCE ROACHES MOVE IN --
>> HEY, KNOCK IT OFF WITH THE
LIGHT, HUH?
>> THEY MAKE THEMSELVES RIGHT AT
HOME.
>> HA-HA!
THIS KID IS INSANE.
HE WE ACTUALLY SAY ANYTHING.
>> AND BEFORE YOU KNOW IT,
THEY'RE PRACTICALLY PART OF THE
FAMILY.
>> BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO
ROACHES --
>> HELLO?
>> LET'S FACE IT.
>> HON?
>> WHAT'S YOURS --
IS THEIRS.
>> YOU HAD SEX WITH MY WIFE.
>> SOMEBODY HAD TO.
>> THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> GET OUT OF MY HOUSE!
>> OH, BILL, PERFECT TIMING.
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE LOW ON
SNACKS, BUDDY.
>> BILL?
BILL, YOU'RE DRUNK.
>> SHUT UP!
>> WELL, WELL, WELL.
A BIG MAN'S GOT HIMSELF A CAN OF
ROACH-EX PLUS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO WITH
IT, BILL?
ARE YOU GOING TO SPRAY ME?
>> SHUT UP.
>> WELL, SPRAY ME, BILL.
GO AHEAD, DO IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'LL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE HELP.
>> YOU'RE CRAZY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, I'M CRAZY,
BILL.
BLOW ME OUT OF YOUR HOUSE, YOU
JUST GOT TO PUSH THE NOZZLE.
DO IT.
>> I'LL DO IT.
>> DO IT, BILL.
SPRAY ME.
DO IT!
>> I WILL!
>> YOU CAN'T DO IT, CAN YOU,
BILL?
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT A MAN.
YOU'RE NOTHING BUT --
NO!
>> SO SEND ROACHES AN EVICTION
NOTICE WITH ROACH-EX PLUS ROACH
KILLER.
ROACHES DON'T STAND A CHANCE.